[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir leiden oft zu der Vorstellung die
Welt Dreh sich um eine kleine Gruppe
riesiger Supermächte die die Fäden in
der Hand halten die Vereinigten Staaten
China das Vereinigte Königreich bis vor
kurzem vielleicht Russland und in
Zukunft eventuell Indien aber was wäre
wenn ich euch sagen würde dass es viel
kleinere teilweise scheinbar
unbedeutende Länder gibt die plötzlich
gigantischen Einfluss auf globale Ebene
erlangen was wäre wenn wir dabei über
Länder sprechen würden die weder die
reichsten der Welt sind noch unbedingt
Atomwaffen große Armeen oder eine große
Bevölkerung haben ist aber dennoch
fertig bringen konnten sich eine Nische
auf den internationalen geopolitischen
Schachbrett zu schaffen meine Lieben
visualpolitik Zuschauer in diesem Video
zeigen wir euch Beispiele einige Länder
die trotz ihrer geringen Größe alle
Dimensionen überschreiten können doch
zunächst wäre es nicht unangebracht den
ultimativen Schlüssel zu diesem neuen
Einfluss zur beleuchten wir sprechen von
der sogenannten soft power und diese
kann viel wichtiger sein als ihr
vielleicht denkt
man könnte sagen dass diese Art von
Strategie oder macht darin besteht
Menschen auf der ganzen Welt zu
beeinflussen und zu überreden bestimmte
Ziele zu verfolgen ihre Ideen Gedanken
und Überzeugungen subtil zu beeinflussen
und um dies zu erreichen werden Elemente
wie Kulturwerte Innovationen Sport
Diplomatie und sogar Philanthropie
eingesetzt softpower ist das Gegenteil
von hardpower die durch Zwang die
Anwendung von Gewalt oder Drohungen und
wirtschaftliche Erpressung ausgeübt wird
eine Art von macht bei der ist nicht
sonderlich überrascht dass ausgerechnet
die Großmächte bei ihr große Vorteile
haben mit anderen Worten während harte
Macht von Gewalt abhängt wurde weiche
macht auf überzeugungs- und
Anziehungskraft
über den Einfluss von hardpower und
militärischer Präsenz haben wir schon in
vielen Videos gesprochen das ist wie ihr
alle wisst ein wiederkehrendes Thema bei
visualpolitik worüber wir doch selten
gesprochen haben ist wie ein Land seiner
Relevanz und seinen internationalen
Einfluss ausbauen kann indem es auf
Überzeugungsarbeit setzt das kann auch
ein echter Rettungsanker für die
Unternehmen und die Exportprodukte des
Landes sein und glaubt mir das ist kein
Scherz viele Länder sind bereits dabei
diese Art von Einfluss zu entwickeln
also lasst uns herausfinden welche
Länder durch softbauer in der Lage sind
mit den Großmächten zu konkurrieren und
wie genau sieht das eigentlich anstellen
meine Lieben Politik Zuschauer wir
werden uns jeden Aspekt dieses Ansatzes
ansehen und wisst ihr was wir werden
Ihnen mit konkreten Beispielen
veranschaulichen lasst uns aber vorher
noch einen wichtigen werde Hinweis
unseres tollen Sponsors surfshark
einspielen damit wir danach sofort
fortfahren können denn es Sascha GPN ist
ein wirklich empfehlenswertes und
sicheres VPN welches z.B keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten natürlich kann ein
Deutschland privat nicht vor allen
gefahrenschützen denen es lauert man
muss nach wie vor Umsicht walten lassen
und wissen was man tut aber es stellt
hierfür ein Werkzeug mit gleich mehreren
Vorteilen da zum einen erschwert ist in
Kombination mit anderen Vorkehrungen
eure Aktion im Netz nachzuverfolgen und
abzuhören mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheitsfeatures könnt ihr so eure
Annuität in Netz erhöhen z.B mit dem
integrierten klimap dass alle
unerwünschten Cookies und Pops Block
weiterer Vorteil ist dass ihr so tun
könnt als während ihr an einem anderen
Ort so könnt ihr z.B auch Webseite und
Internet
verfügbar werden auch daheim oder in
Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt sowieso
Netflix und anderes
anbieten von Europa oder deutsches
Internet fernsehen im Außen angucken
willst du offline kein Problem aber das
ist noch lange nicht alles mit nur einem
Surfer konnte wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte Info ob in registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode politik.de
angeht bekommt
83% und obendrein die ersten drei Monate
gratis dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video also nichts los besorgt
damit gleichzeitig auch kurz finanziell
unter die Arme das könnt ihr übrigens
auch direkt mit Hilfe der Spenden Links
die ich euch ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind euch
für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hätten wir uns euch in Zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere Videos zu
liefern so und nun lasst uns zu einer
Reise aufbrechen als erstes sehen wir
uns die aufstehende Kultur macht
Südkorea an aufgepasst
Aufstieg der k-power
eines der Länder das in letzter Zeit
seinen internationalen Einfluss am
stärksten ausgebaut und sein Image
verbessert hat ist ja in der Tat
Südkorea sicherlich kein kleines Land
außer vielleicht der Flächen nach aber
auch nicht gerade vergleichbar mit
riesen wie China oder den Vereinigten
Staaten hier auf visualpolitik haben wir
schon in mehreren Videos über Südkorea
gesprochen wir haben über politische
wirtschaftliche militärische und sogar
soziale Themen gesprochen aber wir haben
nie erwähnt wie dieses Land zu einem der
beliebtesten Länder der Welt geworden
ist ihr alle habt sicher schon von K-Pop
oder koreanischen Serien gehört die
Netflix in Stürme erobert haben wie zum
Beispiel the scritt game aber lange vor
all dem bevor gängiges Teil für lange
Zeit das meist gesehene Video auf
Youtube wurde bevor Gruppen wie BTS oder
blackpink die Welt eroberten und bevor
der Film parasite die Oscars gewonnen
hatte die sogenannte koreanische Welle
13 asiatischen Kontinent erobert
vielleicht sind einige von euch durch
all das ermutigt worden koreanisches
Essen zu probieren eine Küche die
ebenfalls immer mehr an Beliebtheit
gewählt
[Musik]
Kino Musik Kultur und Gastronomie das
mag uns vielleicht nicht als besonders
bedeutend erscheinen aber es ist nicht
erstaunlich dass ein verhältnismäßig
kleines Land wie dieses einen solchen
globalen Einfluss hat habt ihr zum
Beispiel schon mal über die Autos
nachgedacht die systematisch in
koreanischen Fernsehserien auftauchen
wenn ich dann schaut mal nach aber es
sind fast immer entweder Hyundai Genesis
oder Kia man könnte fast von einer mega
Werbekampagne für einen der wichtigsten
Industriezweige des Landes sprechen und
natürlich reden wir nicht über Autos
aber auch das ist nur ein Aspekt dieser
riesigen globalen werbevorstellung im
Falle Südkoreas ist diese Art der
Aufmerksamkeit nicht aus dem Nichts
gekommen ganz im Gegenteil wir könnten
so weit gehen zu sagen dass dies seit
mehreren Jahrzehnten ein Teil der
staatlichen koreanischen Strategie ist
[Musik]
einige Experten sind der Meinung dass
die Unterstützung durch die Regierung
der Schlüssel zum sogenannten halover
der koreanischen Welle kultureller
Inhalte die in den 1990er Jahren aufkam
so kündigte der damalige Präsidenten
Jones 1998 den ersten Plan zur
Unterstützung der halo-industrie an ziel
war es die Kulturindustrie anzukurbeln
und sie zu einem großen Aushängeschild
für das ganze Land zu machen und ich
garantiere euch das war nicht nur heiße
Luft in nur drei Jahren verdreifachte
sich das öffentliche Budget für die
Kulturindustrie der Erfolg war so
durchschlagen dass die nächste Regierung
die von Roman die Investitionen in die
Kulturindustrie weiter erhöhte es wurden
sogar mehrere Gesetze erlassen und
Regierung Stellen eingerichtet die
ausschließlich der Förderung dieser
kulturellen Inhalte innerhalb und
außerhalb des Landes dienten
aber ich weiß was ihr denkt wenn es so
einfach wäre man einfach nur Geld in die
Hand nehmen muss dann könnten viele
andere Länder das doch auch tun oder
und damit habt ihr natürlich recht ganz
so einfach ist es dann doch nicht
tatsächlich ist es so dass in diesem
Fall der Schlüssel zum Erfolg der
koreanischen Welle nicht wirklich der
wirtschaftliche Beitrag der Regierung
war sondern vor allem die Qualität der
Inhalte und die Tatsache dass der
Prozess vollständig von privaten
Unternehmen und Produktionsfirmen
geleitet und verwaltet wurde die auf
Profit aus waren sagen wir einfach dass
die Regierung in diesem Fall eine
ähnliche Rolle gespielt hat Widerstand
Israel bei der Förderung von
Technologieunternehmen darüber haben wir
zum Beispiel schon mehreren Videos
sowohl Politik als auch visualökonomik
berichtet und ich werde sie euch
verlinken das heißt der Staat stellte
das Geld zur Verfügung um die Industrie
zu unterstützen überließt ihr aber die
gesamte Kontrolle und zwar mit einer
ganz klaren Prämisse sie mussten aus
eigener Kraft wettbewerbsfähig werden
das heißt sie mussten so viel Geld wie
möglich verdienen und so förderte der
Staat nach und nach einem Sektor der ihm
viel internationale Aufmerksamkeit
bringen könnte sich an
Kultur hat sich als unverzichtbares
Element für die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
einer Nation und als wirtschaftliche
Ressource erwiesen die einen Mehrwert
schafft um mit diesem sich wandelnden
globalen Umfeld Schritt zu halten hat
Korea die kulturdiplomatie zu einer
neuen Säule seiner Diplomatik gemacht
unglaubt mir wenn ich euch sage dass sie
dies sehr ernst nehmen das
südkoreanische Außenministerium für z.B
Untersuchungen über den Einfluss von
hallju in jedem Land durch und fördert
auch der Grundlage dieser Ergebnisse
Fanaktivitäten und kulturelle
Veranstaltungen ein weiteres Beispiel
ist das die Regierung 20 bis 30% eines
riesigen 1 Milliarden Dollar
Investitionsfonds sponsert der darauf
abzielt die koreanische Popkultur
auszubauen und zu exportieren wie ihr
seht kommt deren Erfolg also nicht von
ungefähr
[Musik]
und die Frage lautet wozu eigentlich nur
eines der Ziele dieses starken
Engagements war es das internationale
Image Südkoreas zu verbessern ein Land
das seit seiner Gründung im Jahr 1948
einen verheerenden Krieg und bis in den
90er Jahre eine Reihe von Militär
Diktaturen erlebt hat Diktaturen unter
denen ist natürlich ständig zum
Menschenrechtsverletzungen kam und daher
eher zum negativen Image des Landes im
Ausland beitrugen lange Zeit als
Südkorea als eine Art mega Fabrik die
von Treppen und riesigen Familienkonzern
geführt und durch korrupte Politiker
gestürzt wurden wie ihr euch vorstellen
könnt war das nicht gerade die beste
Visitenkarte
[Musik]
und als die Demokratie in dem Land das
als das Land der Morgenstille bekannt
ist Einzug hielt mussten sich die
Politiker nicht nur an die Arbeit machen
um die Institutionen zu säubern nein sie
mussten auch hart daran arbeiten dass
Image des Landes in und Ausland zu
verbessern und da habt ihr es der Bedarf
war da der Wille auch also haben sie die
Ärmel hochgekrempelt und wisst ihr was
es gibt einfach Fakten die uns helfen
können den enormen Erfolg den sie hatten
wirklich zu verstehen nach Angaben der
Welt Tourismusorganisation ist die Zahl
der Touristen ist Südkorea zwischen 1995
und 2019 den letzten Daten vor der
Pandemie um
367% gestiegen von etwa 3,75 Millionen
auf fast 18 Millionen der Tourismus
entwickelte sich also zu einer riesigen
und völlig neuen Einnahmequelle
[Musik]
eine weitere Tatsache die den Einfluss
dieses kulturellen Engagements zeigt ist
die Zahl der Menschen die sich plötzlich
dazu entschließen die koreanische
Sprache zu lernen dazu können wir uns
zum Beispiel die Zahl der Schüler
ansehen die sich jedes Jahr zu
offiziellen Prüfungen anmelden und die
Zahl der Topic Bewerber ist zwischen
1997 und 2019 um sagenhafte
14.000% gestiegen zum Vergleich im Jahr
2019 gab es auch 400.000 Bewerber das
ist von viermal mehr als z.B bei den
offiziellen dänischen spanischsprüfungen
also ein vorher hier unvorstellbarer
Erfolg und vergessen wenn nicht das
koreanisch mit nur 80 Millionen
muttersprachland weltweit eine
Minderheitensprache ist was diese Zahlen
zu einem echten Meilenstein machen
[Musik]
zum Vergleich sei auch angemerkter
Spanien jedes Jahr 170 Millionen Euro
für das verwandtes Institut ausgeht im
Wesentlichen für sein Hauptsitz seine
Zweigstellen und seine Angestellten eine
Institution der wichtigste Aufgabe darin
besteht die spanische Sprache in der
Welt zu fördern und was soll ich sagen
die Daten sprechen eine deutliche
Sprache Südkoreas Engagement für private
Unternehmen und wettbewerbsfähige
Inhalte war eindeutig erfolgreicher vor
allem wenn man bedenkt dass die
spanische Sprache weltweit die
zweitgrößte Anzahl an Muttersprache an
hat und allgemein viel viel
einflussreicher ist als koreanisch
tatsache ist dass all diese Auswirkungen
natürlich eine riesige zusätzliche
Einnahmequelle für die südkoreanische
Wirtschaft darstellen und das ist noch
nicht alles es ist auch eine Möglichkeit
das politische Image Südkoreas in der
Welt zu fördern was neben der Steigerung
des Handels des diplomatischen und
politischen Ausbaus besonders wichtig
sein könnte wenn es z.B zu einem
Konflikten mit Nordkorea kommt denn es
ist klar dass Dinge die wir kennen und
schätzen für uns viel wichtiger sind es
handelt sich um eine Strategie die
Länder wie Israel ebenfalls verfolgen
ist euch z.B aufgefallen dass es immer
mehr israelische Inhalte aufs
trainingsplattformen gibt es lohnt sich
durchaus dass zur Kenntnis zu nehmen es
hat mehr Auswirkungen als ihr vielleicht
denkt seht euch zum Beispiel diese
Nachricht an Pfau das vierte Staffel
Bericht Zuschauerrekorde im Nahen Osten
Netflix umstrittene Serie da steht in
arabischen Ländern ganz oben auf der
watch lässt faul da ist eine Serie die
sich mit dem israelisch
verläsidentinischen Konflikt beschäftigt
eine auf Hebräisch produzierte Serie die
jetzt dazu beiträgt das Bild dieses
Konflikt in den AR abischen Ländern zu
verändern denn ja genau dort ist die
extrem populär natürlich ist der Einsatz
von Kultur nur ein Beispiel aber es ist
bei weitem nicht die einzige Möglichkeit
ähnliche Ziel zu erreichen es gibt noch
andere Möglichkeiten die ein abgelegenes
oder von der Bevölkerungszahl her
relativ kleines Land zu einer
einflussreichen Weltmacht machen können
interessiert euch worum ist dabei geht
dann passt jetzt gut auf
[Musik]
die Macht des scheckbuchs
abgesehen von Filmen Fernsehserien und
Musik die zweifelskrone hervorragende
Instrumente zu Verbesserung des Images
eines Landes darstellen gibt es in
Wahrheit noch viel mehr ein
außerordentlich deutliches Beispiel ist
der Fall Qatar und nein keine Sorge
werden nicht noch einmal im Detail auf
die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in Katar
eingehen obwohl diese eigene sicherlich
sehr viel mit dem zu tun hat worüber wir
sprechen aber darüber haben wir bereits
ein Video gedreht was euch verlinken
Katar ist ein Beispiel für eine große
politische Marketing-Kampagne und eine
wirtschaftskampagne aber es gibt noch
etwas Wichtigeres als das viele von euch
werden wahrscheinlich schon wissen dass
Katara eine der größten Exporteure von
Kohlenwasserstoffen auf der Welt ist das
Land ist vor allem auf den Export von
verflüssigten Erdgas spezialisiert was
ist zu einem der reichsten Länder der
Welt gemacht hat Katara hat also Geld in
Überfluss und wisst ihr was es gibt
einen Weg dieses Geld zu nutzen um nicht
nur profitabel zu sein sondern auch
Einfluss zu gewinnen wie wir euch
bereits in der Vergangenheit berichtet
haben investiert das im Iran am
Persischen Golf einen großen Teil der
Gewinne sehr kohlenwasserstoffausbeutung
über einen staatsvornamens Katar
Investment Autorität
[Musik]
the form verfügt über ein Vermögen von
mehr als 450 Milliarden Dollar was mehr
als 150.000 Dollar pro Einwohner und
mehr als eine Million Dollar pro
katarischen Staatsbürger entsprechend
der Großteil dieses Geldes etwa 400
Milliarden Dollar ist in 80
verschiedenen Ländern investiert wobei
das Vereinigte Königreich mit etwa 40
Milliarden Dollar die meisten
katarischen Investitionen hat z.B
besitzen die katharis und 12 Milliarden
Dollar ein Immobilien in ganz
Großbritannien außerdem ist dieser
größte Immobilien in London und hat auch
in Städten die Paris und Washington DC
beträchtige Investitionen in Immobilien
getätigt
[Musik]
und die Wahrheit ist dass diese Liste
bis ins unendlich fortgesetzt werden
könnte aber natürlich reden wir nicht
nur über Immobilien wir reden vor allem
über strategische Wetten Katars Clown
reichen zum Beispiel auch in den Bereich
der kritischen Infrastruktur das Land
hat sehr viele Häfen und
flüssigkeitsterminals im Rest der Welt
gekauft teilweise ganz teilweise nur
anteilig und davon ist auch an vielen
multinationalen Unternehmen beteiligt
diese z.B einer der größten Aktionäre
der Volkswagen Gruppe die Kontrolle über
diese Infrastruktur und die
Beteiligungen vielen großen Unternehmen
gibt der katholischen Regierung einen
enormen Einfluss auf dem gesamten
Planeten aber wartet ein Moment denn das
ist noch nicht das Ende der Geschichte
das Geld aus Katar hat auch noch andere
Alternative Verwendungszwecke
[Musik]
in ihrem Streben nach politischem und
sozialen Einfluss haben sie viel in die
Welt des Sports investiert wie ihr
sicher alle wisst ist Katar Eigentümer
des Fußballvereins Paris St Germain er
ist momentan ihr bekanntestes
Aushängeschild und jetzt wollen sie auch
noch die Kontrolle über Manchester
United übernehmen auch dafür führende
Fernsehsender der arabischen Weltalter
Sira ist ein katarischer Sender mit
anderen Worten Katar setzt Öl und
gasgelder ein um nicht nur Gewitter zu
erzielen sondern auch politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Einfluss zu gewinnen
sie kontrollieren riesige Medien große
Fußballvereine wichtige Infrastruktur
und halten große Anteile in einem der
wichtigsten multinationalen Unternehmen
der Welt die Kataris werden immer an der
Haustür bekommen geheißen obwohl das
Land nur 2,7 Millionen Einwohner hat von
den nur etwas mehr als 300.000
vollwertige Staatsbürger sind es handelt
sich um einen außergewöhnlichen Einsatz
von Geld um nicht nur Rentabilität
sondern auch Power zu erreichen duha ist
zu einer der großen politischen
Hauptstädte arabischen Welt geworden und
das schickbuch hat dabei eine
Schlüsselrolle gespielt ganz nebenbei
gesagt hat das katarische Geld auch dazu
beigetragen die Verbrüderung mit der
Türkei zu fördern und ja es stimmt das
Katar auch viele Aktionen rein
politischer Natur entwickelt hat wie zum
Beispiel die Unterstützung der
Muslimbrüder oder militärischer Natur
wie zum Beispiel die Überlassung der
größten Militärbasis im Nahen Osten an
die USA aber die Wahrheit ist dass das
checkbuch die zentrale Rolle dabei
gespielt hat Doha viel wichtiger und
einflussreicher zu machen als zum
Beispiel Kuwait ein potentiell noch
reicheres Land sagen wir einfach dass es
ein weiterer Schlüssel zur softpower ist
die vorhandenen Ressourcen zu nutzen um
Einfluss zu gewinnen es mag euch
offensichtlich erscheinen aber
tatsächlich ist es gar nicht so üblich
wie man meinen könnte doch bevor wir
dieses Video beenden können wir nicht
übersehen dass es neben den Einsatz von
Kultur und Geld noch einen dritten Weg
geht der relativ kleinen Länder zur
Verfügung steht um zu politischen
Großmächten zu werden an ihr schaut
worauf ich hinaus bin so und passt jetzt
gut aus
[Musik]
Herzen
[Applaus]
eine weitere Möglichkeit mit den
Mächtigsten michten der Welt zu
konkurrieren besteht darin sich für
gerechte Anliegen und politische
Projekte stark zu machen um euch das zu
erklären wollen wir uns zwei sehr
unterschiedliche Beispiele ansehen
Kanada und Kuba wir sprechen über zwei
Länder die in völlig unterschiedlichen
geopolitischen Bereichen spielen ist
aber beiden gelungen ist ihre Stärken
auszunutzen um regionale und sogar
internationale Bedeutung zu erlangen nun
stellt sich die Frage wie haben Sie das
geschafft nun Kanada z.B hat es
geschafft ein Vorreiter für Bürgerrechte
und Umweltschutz zu werden Kanada ist
zum Beispiel eines der Länder die die
unerklärung über die rechte indigene
Völker am erntesten genommen haben und
ja ich weiß was ihr denkt das klingt
alles schön und gut aber kann man damit
wirklich internationalen Einfluss
gewinnen und die Wahrheit ist ja es kann
sich um eines der wichtigsten
Instrumente handeln um Einfluss zu
gewinnen und Kanada ist ein gutes
Beispiel dafür
dass nach Bevölkerungszahl er kleine
nordamerikanische Land war in den
letzten Jahrzehnten einer der
wichtigsten Förderer internationaler
Verträge so gibt es zum Beispiel den
1997 unterzeichnet von Vertrag der das
Verbot von antibi Personen nehmen zum
Ziel hat oder das Montrealer Protokoll
von 1987 das Richtige für die
Reduzierung des Einsatzes von FCKWs zum
Schutzschicht festlegen
[Musik]
und viele von Euch mögen all diese Dinge
für irrelevant halten aber die Wahrheit
ist dass sie alle dazu beitragen die
Marke eines Landes aufzubauen und seine
internationale Einfluss zu erhöhen seht
es doch mal so jeder möchte den
beliebtesten Schüler in der Klasse nahe
sein und das ist etwas das Regierungen
Unternehmen Investitionen Produkte und
Fachkräfte betrifft es ist gewissermaße
wie Marketingkampagne des Lebens die auf
Länder angewandt wird aber was ist mit
Kuba warum haben wir eine so verarmtes
Land in dieses Video aufgenommen wo es
doch eine kommunistische Diktatur ist
[Musik]
auch wenn es widersprüchlich erscheinen
mag ist genau das der Punkt eine so
armes Land die Kuh war das weder ein
immenses investment portfolio noch
bedeuten Unternehmen noch eine moderne
Armee noch sonst irgendwas hat hat es
trotzdem geschafft zu einem der
einflussreichsten Länder Amerikas zu
werden aber wie haben die Kubaner das
erreicht nur indem sie auf politische
Strategien zurückgreifen in einem
früheren Video hier haben wir z.B
gezeigt wie Sie die Ärzte eingesetzt
haben aber das ist nur ein Beispiel Kuba
geht noch viel weiter und wenn sich die
Insel durch irgendwas auszeichnet dann
durch den intensiven Einsatz der
populistischen Strategie die wir als die
unterworfenen Länder gegen die USA und
Europa zusammenfassen können also die
armen unterdrückten Länder die gegen die
imperialistischen und ausbeuterischen
Mächte USA und Europa auch Begehren
dieser Diskurs sind viele
lateinamerikanischen Ländern schon oft
durchgesetzt wie zum Beispiel in
Venezuela wo ist in Kubanern zuerst
gelungen ist mit Hugo West eine
marionettendiktatur zu errichten und als
nächsten genialen Schritt konnten sie
mit zu elas Öl Geld ihre eigene
Revolution im restlichen Lateinamerika
finanzieren ja das Konzept scheint
wirklich brillant zu sein sicherlich
moralisch verwerflich aber brillant
überall auf den Kontinent hat Kuba
politische Parteien soziale
Interessengruppen und sogar
institutionelle fuhren die das bekannte
Forum von Paulo gefördert Räume aus den
Politik die Rafael Korea Evo moralis
Daniel artiga und Manuel Sella
hervorgegangen sind die Idee auf der der
kubanischen Einfluss in Lateinamerika
beruhte war ganz pragmatisch das
pastor-rechen erkannte dass die Linke in
Lateinamerika kein Erfolg haben würde
wenn sie nicht zumindest in der
öffentlichen Wahrnehmung die alten
Dogmen ablegte Dokument wie die
Abschaffung des privat Eigentums oder
die Errichtung proletarischer Diktaturen
[Musik]
aber abgesehen von der rein
ideologischen Frage welches Interesse
könnte Kuba daran haben seine Revolution
zu exportieren nun für viele Analysten
besteht das Hauptziel darin die Existenz
des kubanischen Regimes zu sichern mit
dem Untergang des Sowjetunion Anfang der
90er Jahre oder daraus resultierenden
schweren wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
Krise in dem karibischen Land erkannten
die Castros dass sie ein internationales
Unterstützungsnetzwerk brauchten alleine
gegen die Vereinigten Staaten zu stehen
versprachen nur wenig Erfolg dieses
Netzwerk von Unterstützern musste in
Lateinamerika entstehen in Ländern die
nahe beieinander liegen in dieser
Sprache sprechen und mehr oder weniger
dieselbe Kultur teilen und wisst ihr was
es hat sich wirklich gelohnt und
Nachrichten wie diese sind der Beweis
dafür wie ein kleines rückständiges und
verarmtes Land enormen international
Einfluss erlangen kann 50% des von
Venezuela produzierten Benzin wird nach
Kuba geliefert sagt ein
Gewerkschaftsführer aus diesem Land nur
zehn Prozent des produzierten Benzins
erreicht die Bevölkerung wie ihr seht
gibt es viele Möglichkeiten globalen
Einfluss zu erlangen auch wenn man eine
relativ kleines Land auf der
internationalen Bühne ist
von Südkoreas kulturellen Inhalten bis
zu Kubas revolutionärer Politik von
Katars makroökonomischen Investitionen
bis zu Kanadas Philanthropie klar ist
das praktisch jedes Land zu einer
geopolitischen macht werden kann wenn es
nur ein wenig Kreativität und gut
vermarkbare globale Visionen entwickelt
und keine Frage alle Länder die wir in
diesem Video gesehen haben haben mit
dieser Art von Strategie große Erfolge
erzielt es handelt sich also um keine
triviale oder vernachlässigbare
Angelegenheit aber an diesem Punkt
angelangt seit erstmal ihr an der Reihe
glaubt Ihr dass euer Land den Beispiel
eines dieser Länder folgen könnte um
mehr internationale Präsenz zu zeigen
glaubt ihr dass diese Art von
Anziehungskraft auf Dauer anhalten kann
oder betrachtet ihr softpower er als
flüchtig und unzuverlässig wie immer
sind auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns ein Leid als mit euren
Freunden und diskutiertes mit ihnen
verges bitte auch nicht unseren Kanal zu
abonnieren unbedingt mit Glöckchen und
keines unserer zukünftigen Videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich wollen wir solche
Zeit über eine Spende von euch müssen
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]